Kremlin is closely following
developments in Washington on the
Russian investigation Charlie d'Agata is
in Moscow with reaction this morning to
Jared Kushner statements about his
contacts with the Russians Charlie good
morning good morning the Kremlin said
today that this Russian banker in
question certain gate Gourcuff mentioned
in Margaret's report there did not need
or receive Kremlin backing in order to
meet with Jared Kushner once again the
Kremlin backing away from any direct
involvement in these meetings that took
place as for ambassador Issa gay kiss
lyac former ambassador kiss lack he's
gone to ground after returning to Russia
a few days ago a much more pressing
matter for the Russians today is the
question of sanctions further sanctions
and strengthening those already in place
yesterday Kremlin spokesman Dmitry
Peskov warned that talks aimed at
imposing further sanctions would prove
harmful and counterproductive not just
to Russia but to the United States and
to European partners who were involved
in large-scale projects primarily in the
energy sector as for President Vladimir
Putin he's now meeting with Iraqi vice
president Nouri al-maliki today we may
hear from him later but again the main
issue is focusing on these sanctions the
debates taking place in Washington and
the impact that they may have on the
already strained relationship between
the United States and Russia gal gadot
Charlie d'Agata reporting from Moscow
thank you